Excusez-moi, y’a quelqu’un là.
J’ai un pote, enfin il est pas là
mais il va arriver donc euh ….
Ah désolé, c’est votre place?
Bah euh, je sais pas.
Ca va, ça fait longtemps que t’es là?
Non, non.
Tu prends quelque chose?
Euh ouais, un coca
et du charisme aussi.
Quoi?
Non, c’est rien, c’est juste que j’ai pas de charisme.
Arrête avec ça! T’as du charisme.
J’ai du charisme? Attends...
S’il vous plait!
Oui, bon, là il était occupé.
Ok, attends...
S’il vous plait!
S’il vous plait, excusez-moi...
Mademoiselle...
Ca ça n’a rien à voir avec le charisme.
Toi tu marmonnes. T’es là :
«s’il vous plait».
Oui ?
Je vous sers quelque chose?
Oui, moi je vais prendre un demi
et puis mon ami prendra un coca.
Ah vous attendez quelqu’un?
*tousse bruyamment*
Ah, pardon Monsieur, je ne vous avais pas vu, haha !
Sans glaçons le coca s’il vous plaît.
Ok, c’est parti.
Je capte pas l’attention des gens.
Ils me voient et ils m’oublient, c’est instantané.
Attends, moi je t’ai pas oublié.
Ah ouais? On s’est rencontrés quand?
En 2007.
Je me souviens, t’étais bizarre.
*hurlements*
Ben en fait, on s’est rencontré en 2002...
Pierre.
-Stéphane.
En 2004.
Pierre.
Ouais, ouais, on s’est déjà …
Stéphane.
En 2004 encore...
Pierre.
*soupir*
Stéphane.
En 2005...
Pierre.
Oh putain... Sérieux?
Stéphane.
Et en 2007.
Pierre.
*hurlements*
Stéphane.
Donc tu comprends quoi...
-Ouais.
Quand je te dis que je capte pas l’attention des gens...
Non mais c’est incroyable ça !
Je la connais la fille, c’est qui?
Non mais c’est une blague?
Oh, pardon.
Mais évidemment que c’est une blague !
Je te rappelle.
Merci.
Allez : à l’amitié,
à nos rencontres et à …
T’avais commandé …
Un coca, ouais.
Non mais c’est n’importe quoi ces histoires de charisme.
C’est juste que toi tu marches pas sur la tête des gens.
Et malheureusement les gens, quand tu les bouscules pas un peu,
c’est eux qui te bousculent.
Toi tu penses aux autres avant de penser à toi.
Alors ouais, on te remarque pas forcément tout de suite.
Mais quand on t’a remarqué,
ben on regrette pas.
Parce que t’es un mec bien,
au cas où t’aurais pas …
T’es con.
Ouais je sais.
Mais en attendant le con,
il t’invite.
*discussion de groupe*
Moi je vais y aller là...
Je ….
Parce que je suis...
je suis un peu crevé donc …
Je vais y aller.
Parce qu’en fait moi je prends la 11
après c’est direct pour chez moi donc euh … Je...
C’est pratique du coup.
Je …
Ben j’y vais du coup.
Salut...
...les gars.
J’y vais là hein!
Là j’y vais.
Je suis parti.